[Music]
yeah I'm all GoPro now lately I like it
good the audio is good it's waterproof
its indestructible
I hate cameras man I'm not a camera guy
I'm telling you to shoot something nice
and laod you do it nice camera again
alright what's up people today we are
doing a pickup shots for danger boys
sorry I did not vlog at all during the
production of danger voice because I'm
directing it and everyone is asking me
damn questions like this guy kept asking
me questions it's my job to ask you
questions yes it is my job to fulfill
the to fulfill the desires of the
director thank you so much for filling
my desires you have Nicky on set amazing
welcome very very serious scene okay
we're talking about drugs we're talking
about crime spoilers and we're talking
about gangs Oh what's the spoiler that
we're talking about gangs I'm
particularly proud of this setup that we
have here because we were too cheap to
get an actual newscast set right all the
money went to you alright we should we
should retask guys I think but yeah we
have a projector for the background and
I think it's really cool cause it kind
of was like a green screen in the final
product without actually using a green
screen because I'm not a big fan of
green screens and yeah it looks kind of
cool alright just finished the pickup
shot with Nicky Edit it's coming along
really really well when I get back home
I might show you a little bit of a sneak
peek like a split second or maybe like
two frames as I was saying it out loud I
was like
I can do that my name Bart was true but
no one's actually shown like the actual
footage yet I'm the only one that has it
yeah you guys want to see like a couple
footage clips of stuff stuff
I don't know anyways uh speaking of like
filmmaking and stuff you know I'm a big
fan of film you guys know that I want to
make movies one day and this this
project for danger boys is a really good
step in the right direction and finally
after five years we were finally doing
something with JK outside of JK I also
like to do my own stuff and I like to
write my own movies as well but because
it's my own stuff and it's not for a
bigger company I tend to I don't hold it
as important as at things for JK r and
so then I kind of just let go of all the
responsibilities yeah there's no
accountability for your own stuff so the
deme has come up with an idea to hold
myself and him himself accountable for
writing a movie yeah because it's like
if I don't have someone else that's
pushing me to do it cuz it's the same
thing I do it's like I have all this
other work that's really important
people are relying on it needs to get
done but the movie is something that
could push my career like further than
anything right now and it's the one
thing that I only want to do for my
career
yeah but because it's only on myself I
haven't done it so I mean Casey always
been talking about you play finishing it
so I was like hey let's just set a hard
date that it's a good amount of time
because we do have husband to take care
of thank you thank you guys but if it's
not something that we like set in stone
we're not gonna get done so I told Casey
I was like what's gonna be challenging
for us that we do not want to have to do
as a punishment cuz if you don't set a
punishment there's nothing like okay we
could push it back another month we
could keep doing that so we're like
how's their bed this is a bed yeah
what's the bet against ourselves yeah I
have to finish Mario to finish or yeah
we bought that finish well I guess it's
more of a challenge because Charles not
a bet yeah challenge is if we both do it
then we know
yeah true so it's good and then we got a
let's go out and eat good food after you
get through by when what when when is
the March first
okay we're vlogging this sounds like
real now and people could keep us up
like check on us a hundred percent March
first
we're both gonna have to have our
scripts done and they're gonna have a
table read for it right the table we
could be that month or whenever but
we're gonna have to hand each other our
scripts or hand bar and Joe our scripts
to tell and they're gonna see this and
they're gonna say okay you guys they're
the judges the judges okay well you
can't just write one page and or like
download a scrip online and give it to
them your idea yeah good well they're
gonna do it like this isn't it cuz I'm
gonna make sure you do it so it's a the
bet or the challenge is a thousand
burpees like that like you know what a
probably is they're not fun I thought do
it get it for you real quick
come on up see I haven't trained
I haven't trained in like a year the
easy one either no jumps no jumps no no
push up just just just plank the plank
one I like the penguin that's too hard a
thousand of those you just go down to
the plank yeah there you go and then and
in don't jump don't jump no jumps like
always with all the ground will push up
and and a jump and a clap best and the
clap de clap engages your shoulder
muscle muscles a little bit more
commercials Marshall says that but the
kicker is there's no breaks a thousand
of them I'm gonna be there to make sure
each other does it but the worst part
about it is a teaspoon of the atomic
what does it call the atomic I don't
know what I'm talking about some
sriracha saw rock you don't know
sriracha Tapatio flashbang there you go
the flashbang I took it play it like on
a needle a drop of it and almost died so
we're gonna do a full teaspoon because
it has to be something that we both
don't want to do I don't you know I
don't what I don't like I don't like
ketchup
I don't like steaks either so yeah yeah
yeah will either stay
something that's like horrible do you
want to get this done or not yes I do
but most cut downs with chalice I might
be more down for the spicy thing than
the the burpees a thousand burgers dude
well that wasn't burpees that's like I
do 20 and I'm already out of breath
let's leave it up to them what do you
guys think is a bad choice for us to do
that has to be like bad but not kill us
and then that's gonna be our punishment
and then you guys keep us accountable
because we're gonna have two movies for
you guys written what do you think
they'll say like you pretty bad I don't
comment down below in the comments and
let us know what kind of punishments we
should give ourselves all right well
we've got a beer start writing then and
that's left me alone here in my office
so stare at this stuff danger boys pilot
and I have a whole bunch of notes from
the set to tell me which shots were good
and which shots were not so good and I
got my trusty script here the guy need
through editing I currently have this
much done of the editing so that's we're
sitting at 20 minutes on the build-out
of the episode so near the end that's
the whole thing
pretty amazing can't wait to figure out
what we're gonna do next of this project
there's a lot of business stuff that
we're trying to tend to right now in
terms of what is the next step yeah
we'll see I don't know I'll keep you
posted on that and with like all this
momentum right now I really feel like
motivator right now and to write my own
script I've been chipping away at my own
script over the last couple years but
nothing comes to fruition because you're
you're your own biggest critic you're
your own biggest enemy and I end that
for myself so yeah with danger boys
being such an important project of ours
it really sucked that I couldn't vlog
while being on set of danger boys I
would have loved to have blogged it I
would have loved to remember you know
it's a more personal vlog just remember
what it was like to be on set from my
perspective and I wanted to bring you
guys along the way I know
bar Joe Gina Tim and are they all
vlogged on set so definitely go check
out their channels to see what happened
gypsies show up one day and she flogged
a little bit so we had a little bit for
our personal memories we are finally
shooting it today is day two I wasn't
able to be here for day one because I
was filming the hey [ __ ] podcast but
I'm here today for day two I am
technically like the art directing
assistant or something so I had to like
dress up scenes that need to be dressed
up with props and stuff and we just
finished this one scene where I had to
dress up some half-eaten tacos so I was
pretty fun KC's running all over the
place he's the director so he has a lot
of responsibility on his shoulders he
has to make sure to lead the whole truth
he's doing a great job but right now
it's lunchtime everyone is eating some
lunch
oh good job baby you're doing great
really good in the shop thank you
so TIFF was art director she came
through with making dirty plates because
we had to have dirty plates they were
filming something that's a little later
on in the story where they've already
finish eating and so we bought tacos tip
bought tacos just and have a beaten and
messy and yeah I finally did something
in this project this is literally the
very first thing that I've done for this
project but other than fitting in in the
script read mm-hmm how's it but there's
a clutch though something really new
didn't we didn't have anything to do
today oh cool yeah I'm glad I could be
useful mm-hmm what are you eating
sandwich how was day one actually let's
get in the shaving you could tell me
about day one cuz I'm burning up
they won was anyone was someone we
designed the shoe you wanted day one to
be super easy because we're all rusty
right through it acting and rusty with
killing me and rested with directing
everything I whole procedure filming and
so yesterday was we only have two scenes
and one of the scenes wasn't even really
a scene it was like you know we had to
create this mock security footage but
yeah we only had two scenes there was a
lot of downtime like three hours of just
us sitting around but like wow but like
but we rehearsed and you know did a lot
of try to be productive means yeah work
and today's our first like full fledge
like Bam Bam Bam Bam we got something
doing every single waking moment of this
production day yeah until watch happen
soon okay baby you enjoy your lunch
see you later hula is doing amazing
you're producing amazingly I came in and
I was like Julia breeze you need a
breathe girl you need to breathe because
coffee you guys look so good in your
costumes Stern except you took yours off
welcome this is my classroom
Oh especially you did I love your
slicked back hair good yeah it looks so
good with that change you know how much
jock juice every morning I got to see
that change stuff right girl I want to
see that chain look at this danger boys
how come you get to be the lucky one I
get it Jackie Dragon Ball Z Jane I saw
it from my nerd
[Music]
so funny our friends are playing male
strippers the boxes are coming out of
your shorts
[Music]
[Music]